welcome back before we say goodbye we  like to play a quick game of truth or  dare  you can ask me to do anything or dare me  to do anything and today we have kristin  hi kristen hi hi drew hello  there dan oh okay everybody does go for  it you are such an inspiration to all  women and i love your instagram feed and  i dare you to take a picture with me for  your instagram feed it would be my honor  and my pleasure to take a picture with  you  [Applause]  we're gonna take a digital picture  would you mind taking her picture by the  way kayla your outfit today it's killing  me thank you  [Applause]  that is a beautiful dare thank you  kristen so much well guess what kristen  in a few minutes you're gonna have to  check  our feed because we'll be on it together  oh thank you for choosing to spend your  time with us we make this show for you  so  take it with you  [Music]